well you a Supreme Court has rejected
the final appeal from imprisoned former
Illinois governor Rod Blagojevich
virtually guaranteeing he'll remain in
prison for the next six years he's
already been there for quite a while
Fox's Matt Finn has more on that story
he met Tucker the US Supreme Court
turned down former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich his appeal and now he's
basically guaranteed to be behind bars
until 2024 unless the president pardons
him and the two happened to know each
other lavoy which appeared on the
president's former reality show The
Apprentice back in 2012 the former
governor was found guilty on several
corruption charges mostly related to
trying to potentially sell then-senator
Barack Obama's Senate seat that was left
vacant when Obama was elected president
and it was up to bugboy ovitch to fill
his seat the goya [ __ ] was taped by the
FBI saying in part that Obama's vacant
seat was a golden thing he wasn't going
to give up for nothing the disgraced
governor insists he never received a
bribe or a kickback Liguria [ __ ] has
been in the federal prison since 2012
and has filed a series of Appeals which
have all been denied leading up to today
when it was turned down once again in
the highest court now before burger
which was in prison he appeared on
multiple late-night talk shows and
reality TV shows he eventually became a
household name nationwide known for his
flamboyance and fall from grace Tucker
Matt fin thank Sal OTT for that joining
us now is Patricia begoy of it she's the
wife of the former governor Blagojevich
thanks all for coming on thank you so
much for having me
I was never a supporter of your
husband's and I'm sure I'll offend some
viewers but I have to say I thought he
got an awful long time in prison I don't
know all the details of it but I'd be
interested in knowing if you could speak
to the president what would you say what
would be your pitch to pardoning your
husband well you know we were so
disappointed today that the Supreme
Court did not decide to take up our case
and and this very dangerous conflict
that we have in the law right now and
provide clarity that we had hoped for
the clarity that both anyone who runs
for political office and anyone who
donates to those political candidates
really needs this this is so dangerous
because it allows the FBI
and power-hungry overzealous prosecutors
like Patrick Patrick Fitzgerald who
prosecuted both my husband and scooter
libby to go after anyone that they don't
like just because that person might be
unpopular or controversial it's you know
my husband is probably the only person
in the entire history of the united
states who is serving any kind of
sentence for simply asking for campaign
contributions how many years yeah it's a
14-year sentence and he never took a
bribe never took a kickback and never
made any promises to to contributors for
any official acts he never seen ever
took gifts trips cars watches any of
these other things that some of these
other governors have been convicted of
and yet he serves a sentence that's
twice as long as anyone else do you see
him what we go out there you know he's
been out there six years he's in
Colorado and we live in Chicago and the
first couple of years we you know we're
out there quite a bit now we go out
there about four times a year but we
still talk on the phone every single day
but my daughters are growing up you know
my oldest my older daughter is a senior
and in college she's graduating in in
two months and my younger ones in high
school so you know the ability to just
pull them out of school to go see their
dad is it gets harder and harder I'm
just I feel I always feel no matter what
they've done four men in prison and he's
certainly lucky to have you whatever
whatever you think your husband is
governor yeah look he's married to you
thank you very much for that I
appreciate it I appreciate it